un estudiante arma un circuito con una
batería y dos focos en serie luego el
estudiante arma un segundo circuito con
dos focos en paralelo que batería se
agotará primero supón que todos los
focos tienen la misma resistencia supón
que las dos baterías tienen el mismo
potencial eléctrico muy bien vamos a
pensar en esto antes de ver las opciones
entonces en el primer escenario tenemos
nuestra batería terminal positiva
terminal negativa y tenemos dos focos en
serie vamos a dibujarlo de esta manera
tradicionalmente los focos en realidad
son simplemente resistencias que cuando
una corriente pasa a través de ellos se
calientan lo suficiente porque la
energía se disipa y emiten luz visible
así que esta es la primera resistencia o
el primer foco el segundo y regresa de
modo que este es el primer escenario el
segundo escenario se ve de esta manera
positivo negativo donde las resistencias
están en paralelo ellas están en
paralelo de esta manera y nos dicen que
supongamos que los focos tienen la misma
resistencia podemos llamar a las
resistencias r justo así y suponemos que
ambas baterías son idénticas para fines
de este ejercicio entonces una manera de
pensar en esto es cuál será la
resistencia equivalente para estos dos
circuitos en este donde tenemos dos
resistencias en serie
podríamos simplificarlo o podríamos
hacer este circuito como si tuviéramos
la fuente de voltaje que es nuestra
batería
podríamos diseñarlo como un circuito con
una resistencia donde su resistencia es
2 r si queremos pensar en un equivalente
para este circuito en paralelo tenemos
la misma fuente de voltaje y podríamos
diseñarlo con una resistencia allí y
cuál sería esta resistencia cuál sería
el equivalente a estas dos resistencias
en paralelo si llamamos a esta
resistencia a sub dos sabemos que uno
sobre la resistencia sub 2 es igual a 1
sobre r más uno sobre r y esta es la
fórmula para resistencias equivalentes
cuando tenemos resistencias en paralelo
así que esto es igual a 2 sobre r si
tomamos el recíproco de este y de éste
obtenemos que r sub 2 es igual a r sobre
2 éste es igual a r sobre 2 ahora cuál
es la potencia que se disipa en una
resistencia sabemos que la potencia
disipada a través de una resistencia va
a ser igual al voltaje a través de la
resistencia multiplicado por la correa
que atraviesa esa resistencia bueno
sabemos que el voltaje en ambas
resistencias va a ser el mismo entonces
ve va a ser el mismo en cualquier
situación pero qué pasa con la corriente
bien sabemos que b es igual a r por y
otra forma de pensar en esto es que la
corriente es igual al voltaje sobre la
resistencia entonces nuestra corriente
en este primer escenario va a ser igual
a b sobre 2 r mientras que en el segundo
escenario va a ser igual a b sobre ere
sobre 2 que es lo mismo que 2 b sobre r
entonces nuestra corriente en este
segundo escenario va a ser cuatro veces
más grande de modo que si cuadruplica
esta corriente y tienes el mismo voltaje
vas a 4 aplicar la potencia y si estás
cuadruplicando la potencia estás
cuadruplicando la cantidad de energía
que se disipa por unidad de tiempo y así
en este segundo escenario donde
cuadruplicamos la potencia
'estamos cuadruplicando la energía
disipada con el tiempo
esa batería se agotará mucho más rápido
entonces preguntan qué batería se
agotará primero bueno esa va a ser la
batería en el circuito con dos focos en
paralelo y terminamos hasta el próximo
vídeo